>> Now, if we don't look at these, you've seen that the average salary of
Geography majors is about 48,000. However, in the mid 1980s, the average
starting salary of Geography students at the University of North Carolina was
well over 100,000. Why was this? Well, maybe UNC had a really good Geography
program or UNC's career services program found top-tier jobs for students, or
maybe salaries in North Carolina were just higher in the 1980s. Actually, it's
because Michael Jordan graduated from there and his starting salary was over
$500,000. So, you saw that the mode isn't influenced by an outlier at all, but
the mean is influenced a lot. We need something in between. This is where the
median comes in, which is the middle of the data.